um one of the problems that mehmet oz is
facing in his
uh
pennsylvania
um senate candidacy
is that he's running as a republican
and yet he's been pro-choice as far as i
can remember for a really long time
maybe that's changed he previously
supported obamacare he previously
supported health insurance mandates
before turning against them and so there
were some maga people
who were not super big
on mehmet oz
and now trump has endorsed mehmet oz and
it's all going completely and totally
bonkers mega world melting down
melting down
over trump endorsing mem at oz so let's
go first to the clip of trump's
endorsement this was we looked at it
earlier in the context of the rally here
is trump announcing to the crowd he
supports mehmet oz
by the way i endorsed another person
today dr oz in pennsylvania
dr oz
great guy a good man good man harvard
educated
tremendous tremendous career and they
liked him for a long time that's like a
poll you know when you're in television
for 18 years that's like a poll that
means people like you but he's a he's a
great guy
this you know what's crazy
the reasons
that they dislike mehmet oz
are pretty reasonable things like he has
a history of being pro-choice he has a
history of supporting obamacare that is
making them lose their minds over
trump's endorsement of oz
the things that should disqualify him
immediately like the fact that he
promoted
quack cures for colds drinkable silver
you know it's indistinguishable from
alex jones they don't seem to have any
problem with that but
mega world is melting down sean parnell
the former trump endorsed candidate who
had to drop out of the race after an
allegation surfaced from his ex-wife
wrote on twitter
i have enormous respect for president
trump
i was honored to have his endorsement in
pennsylvania twice
but i'm disappointed by this oz is the
antithesis
of everything that made trump the best
president of my lifetime he's the
farthest thing from america first and
he'd be very bad for pennsylvania
right-wing radio host eric erickson
tweeted it's like donald trump's staff
is sabotaging trump by convincing him to
make the worst possible endorsements
breitbart news's joel pollock wrote this
endorsement could divide magga
in the only way that matters he could
lose america first conservatives over it
and then republican mo brooks from
alabama who's running for senate he
recently had a rift with trump trump
unendorsed him he wrote this is
happening because trump surrounded
himself by staff who are on mcconnell's
payroll and hostile to the maga agenda
everybody telling trump who to endorse
in primaries works for the swamp they
played him again
roger stone was on telegram writing wait
president trump endorsed this guy town
hall columnist kurt schlichter
wrote it's pretty hard for me to fully
express how disappointed i am in trump
for endorsing oz from blazetv ally beth
stuckey wrote wait
is there anything conservative about dr
oz so
they don't love trump
they love what they imagine trump to be
and when trump shows what he is which is
he puts his finger to the wind he
supports people he thinks will win he
supports celebrities he loves
celebrities that's what listen what's
the similarity between herschel walker
and mehmet oz there's not much
other than they're both well known in
celebrity space sports tv etc uh trump
gets his information from tv
we should be glad he didn't try
nominating judge judy to the supreme
court because that's how trump makes
decisions the real question is should
oprah be held accountable for unleashing
mehmet oz upon the world i'm half joking
but it's horrible the guy is horrible
herschel walker's horrible mehmet oz is
horrible but if there's anything good
from this it would be hopefully the
division within mega world
over trump's endorsement of um of amet
oz
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 plastic free made
without any virgin tree fibers meaning
no new trees are cut down but real paper
is super soft and durable you don't have
to sacrifice quality to help the planet
these are great products from a
usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable
plastic free packaging everybody needs
paper towels and toilet paper buy ones
that you will feel good about and
they're giving my audience thirty
percent off a subscription when you go
to realpaper.com pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below